believe in yourself you know because we
are all we're all special we're all made
in God's image we have were born to love
and to be loved and practice loving
yourself and being very grateful for
life and all the gifts you given and
practice loving others and doing what
you can
in a small way to help because the world
needs love more than it needs anything
today and be happy it's very important
to be happy in life and if you're not
happy ask yourself why not and quite and
look at all the beauty the music the art
beautiful countries that we have so much
to be grateful for and I think all these
things help us to realize the
magnificence of life the mystery of life
and don't worry too much about all the
problems a lot of people working to help
make the world a better place it's not
up to each of us this is a team effort
and celebrate life be happy and do what
you can to make it very beautiful
whatever your gifts are just try to make
it a better world